[Applaudissements]
quelques mots de leur part ici
bientôt
cela a été une sacrée odyssée au
cours des
cinq six sept huit dernières années
depuis que
Bob et moi avons commencé à travailler sur ce
programme
et d'être là où nous en sommes maintenant le premier
vol brut de euh dragon  est tout simplement
incroyable euh nous l'avons dit avant
juste un immense privilège de faire partie
de ce programme pour faire
partie de la nasa il y a cinq heures, nous étions dans un
vaisseau spatial en
train de faire des appels téléphoniques par satellite à
qui nous pouvions mettre la main,
ce qui était un peu  amusant au fait,
il y a quelque chose de spécial à avoir
cette capacité
de lancer et de ramener vos propres
astronautes à la maison
et euh nous avons traversé de nombreuses années
sans cette capacité
et je pense que nous sommes tous les deux super super fiers
d'avoir été juste une petite partie de  l'
équipe qui a
réussi à ramener ces
vols spatiaux sur la côte de la Floride
aujourd'hui lorsque nous avons reçu les appels de réveil de
nos garçons
nous disant un peu ce qu'ils
attendaient avec impatience, c'est-à-dire nous
rentrer à la maison
et dans le cas de theo